hey everybody I'm Carla hey Carla so I'm
excited to be here tonight and I am
going to read a little excerpt from this
book it is birth school Metallica death
and I happen to throughout the book nice
little amusing excerpt about the Sunset
Strip there is a story told about the
Los Angeles rock scene surf in 1982
which has long since passed into
Metallica war according to legend Lars
Ulrich found himself at the famous
troopa tonight pop on Melrose Avenue one
summer evening when Metallica's
candyfloss haired nemesis Motley Crue
strode into the bar with their entourage
the story has it that the crew party
were intoxicated of nachos and in high
spirits having freshly inked a lucrative
major label deal with Elektra Records
oreck meanwhile was said to have been
drinking alone to numb his growing
frustration over his fans failure to
detonate a bomb under the strip the site
of crew bandleader songwriter and
bassist Nikki Sixx in his coterie
holding court in the in the club that
night then served only to inflame the
drummer sense of injustice drawing
himself to his foe high to be 5 foot 8
inch Dane allegedly approached Motley
Crue's table and informed the group's
towering basis that his band sucked at
which point to house of laughter 6 grab
the impertinent critic bites lapels and
threw him halfway across the room it is
an amusing anecdote one which feeds
nicely into the received wisdom that is
at this time Metallica were fearless
lone wolves who proud hair metal jungle
in search of a kill in truth however the
incident never happened the reality of
the story is rather more prosaic as
James Hetfield remembers it Metallica
did
cross paths with crew one night at the
troubadour but their encounter was made
on uneven terms we were outside a club
sitting on a sitting on a park cart
pissed off and drunk hetfield her fault
we didn't even have enough money to get
into the show so we were sitting outside
trying to weasel or away in some how do
you know meet someone then those guys
Mountain crew came walking out with high
heels and grandma's jewelry on they
walked by Neil you guys suck they turned
around like tough guys just stood there
they look like giants because
they've gotten their Elton John Gilzean
meanwhile we're standing there in our
tennis shoes going huh they
flicked a cigarette on us and walk away
at this time motley crew were abandoned
unhedged delinquents is unlikely to back
down from a fight as they were to
decline a line of cocaine deposited in
the cleavage of a stripper that they
chose not to crack Metallica skulls
against the Melrose Avenue sidewalk that
means said everything about the two
hacks respective fortunes in the summer
of nineteen eighty-two the crew to
borrow a term to borrow a title from
their first seven inch single for the
toast of the town Elia nato's whose
self-financed independently released
1981 debut album too fast for love had
already sold more than 20,000 copies on
their own leather records imprint
Metallica by contrast or a glorified
covers band but the singer who could
barely look at audience in the eyes a
drummer who cannot keep time a
self-obsessed damaged guitarist and a
basis who didn't even want to be in the
verb as oricas often insisted Metallica
may well have defined themselves as the
anti-mafia crew but in haziness days in
1982 the chasm between the two parties
was so vast that the more
establish group were barely aware of
their snotty Brethren's existence tomate
Lee crew Metallica were invisible men
the life-form on worthy of even the most
common of Sunset Strip courtesies
content in true one could that one can
easily view this casual humiliation as
representative of Metallica status
across the Hollywood rock scene as a
whole for while James Hetfield would
once described Los Angeles as being the
place that didn't show his group a lot
of love neither did the city show them
any measure of any measure of
discernible hatred instead the group
were meant with the most galling our
perceptions one of indifference notice
there is no one was in pain tension
Hetfield admitted we were playing people
would just have this loss look on their
faces he said we go man what the is
matter with you give me the fingers spit
on me yell smile do something that makes
angry so that's that little excerpt and
then there's an another little excerpt
that I thought was interesting talking
about in comparison the LA scene in the
San Francisco scene reverie huh the
thing about Metallica is that they were
our band says Doug Goodman an original
observer of the Bay Area metal scene
Goodman wedding time come work as tour
manager for such groups of screen day
and smashing pumpkins his first job in
this field was touring with slavery in
front in front man tom araya camaro car
it didn't matter that they came from
that they came over from Los Angeles as
soon as they played here even before
they drove to San Francisco they were
immediately our band the people in the
scene I den
fighting with them in the strongest way
right from the start of course in time
they come to represent the whole area
but even before that it was obvious that
there was a real connection between what
they represented in what we wanted to
hear considering that Los Angeles and
San Francisco or cities that reside in
the same state and our energy earn an
RNA Geographic sense were relatively
close neighbors the differences between
the two are marked despite its easygoing
languorous exterior Los Angeles is a
city of high achievement a place that
attracts people from all over the
country hoping to make it as such
competition is fierce while camaraderie
is often merely a facade that goes no
deeper than the sweat on each hustler
skin tales abound from Hollywood middle
and hair metal scene of the 80s that
would see band members roaming Sunset
Boulevard taping to lamp posts walls
flyers advertising their groups upcoming
shows over they're announcing
appearances by competitors by comparison
for bands such as Metallica San
Francisco was deja los angeles neon
polluted night as Janis Joplin once
observed the first thing that defines
the music scene San Francisco is tough
the first thing that defines music in
San Francisco's in San Francisco is the
freedom for some reason people gravitate
here and feel free to make any kind of
music they feel they feel like making
artists seeking a location that allows
them to make any kind of music they feel
like making stands in marked contrast to
people relocating to a city in order to
play the kind of music they feel will
enable them to make it Metallica though
made music that well Ferrell that while
Farrell was also finessed and the band
themselves for more than annum
that on loose and looking for trouble in
today's parlance people complain to have
a vision are implying that they
themselves are visionaries but in the
case of Lars Ulrich this could have
Corey he said this this could already be
said to be true Metallica may have worn
their integrity like a patch on the
sleep of the denim jacket but even in
the group's earliest days or compared
not only to have had his eyes fixed on a
larger prize but also to be possessed of
the wit to appreciate the incremental
steps required in order that he and his
bandmates might realize this achievement
relocated to San Francisco may not have
been the drummer's idea that he was
quick to realize the potential gain of
such a move the group's arrival on the
streets of the bay area though was a
less was less of a tale of two cities
and more the story of one implacable
musician that Cliff Burton was able to
spirit virtual strangers away from the
city in which they lived serves to
signify the power of an enigmatic
presence that seemed to be comprised of
little more than human flair and flair